in a historic settlement a gun maker has
agreed to pay for its role in the sandy
hook school massacre a lone gunman
killed 20 children and six adults in
2012. the families of nine of the
victims agreed to a 73 million
settlement with remington arms the
agreement requires remington to release
internal documents showing how it
marketed the ar-15 style rifle used in
the shootings nicki petit spoke to the
families involved in the lawsuit nikki
good morning nate good morning the
families of the victims told me they
know a settlement will never ease their
pain but they do hope it sends a message
to gun makers and the insurance
companies backing them that the loss and
grief they have endured should never
happen to another family
it's not going to stop gun manufacturers
it's not going to stop the sale of
firearms but it's going to ensure that
at least they're done with
responsibility with accountability and
with safety in mind nicole hockley and
the families of eight other sandy hook
victims have spent the last seven years
fighting a battle no one thought they
would win
nicole's son dylan would be 15 years old
this year he was one of the 20 children
and six adults murdered at sandy hook
elementary school december 14 2012. the
fight against remington arms the gun
manufacturer that made the ar-15 used in
the attack was a monumental undertaking
in part because of a 2005 law that
protects gun manufacturers from
litigation once we started seeing the
marketing material that was a big eye
opener attorneys representing the
families argued that remington
deliberately marketed the ar-15 to
troubled young men through placement in
violent video games and advertisements
like this one that says consider your
man card reissued
i know that the headlines today are
going to be a lot about
the 73 million dollars
that is just not really on my radar
it's more about the process of what we
can now do with what we've discovered
and how we can share that to everyone
else
hockley like so many of the parents
wants her son to be remembered beyond
the tragedy what do you hope his legacy
will be
i want him to be remembered as
a beautiful six-year-old boy who helped
create change for others
i don't want people to ever forget his
name
his gorgeous eyes his smile
and i want
his voice to be part of creating that
safer future
in this case the lawyers for the sandy
hook families worked around that federal
law that protects gun makers by arguing
that remington's marketing violated a
specific connecticut consumer law a
similar law is on the books here in new
york in a statement last night president
biden called on congress to repeal the
2005 federal law remington went bankrupt
in 2020 and has in the past denied
allegations against the company we tried
reaching out to remington but have not
heard back that specific connecticut law
is a big reason why this was successful
in the state of connecticut it may not
be a model for everywhere although the
argument can certainly be made i i can't
get over the fact that these kids would
have been 15 16 years old right now it's
just absolutely tragedy gut-wrenching
nikki thank you very much